[Music]
in desperate measures news yes I did it
yes desperate measures
coming this that's a DVD movie is what
it sounds like I'm desperate for others
to DV that sounds like a 2001 Ben
Affleck movie desperate measures he's a
mathematician he does he's measuring
things he's like oh girl was [ __ ] sick
I was the man what you talk about a
movie where the Builder wins crazy
Oh consider one that are spelled it
should have called it giggly batter in
the holy map you guys JLo was killing in
the movies for a minute there was like
maytee Manhattan where she were the
neighbor what's one where she's [ __ ]
the neighbor boy
the younger neighbor boy laughs and then
he sits the house on fire in the end is
tight what oh oh the one we saw was
Michael in the theater where they've
airbrush every single scene shoot every
scene she was in she look waterproof
yeah she looked super airbrushed the
studio civilian was really bad but it
was funny better hmm submitted by I love
gold another article yeah they did yep
drew no what no no no as Mickey's
Mickey's yeah oh you literally see David
sorry no like it's my jewelry line you
could go look at it
okay before calm slash questions last
nickel emo yeah
gettin some coffee just custom jewelry
the jewelry Instagram okay limited time
offer for jewelry bring keys and coffee
I'm Molly I do remember you like I'd
remember saying I love gold earlier but
no other submitted bodies I love gold oh
this is the only one wait thanks Rachel
Angela says I said joe said I love gold
after somebody said to me money trees
money tree the producer and you was
freaking out like it's my fault I [ __ ]
up it's my fault the US healthcare
system has such a bad reputation that
some people will do anything to avoid
you it's blue also in other news listen
I don't even have health care now like
on purpose
oh you're gonna get in trouble yet to
pay the [ __ ] spend my money at the
doctors I mean I should just go get
checkups and [ __ ] just because because
of how much [ __ ] I'm money I'm
spending we place x4 understand why
can't my monthly bill go towards my
deductible oh because they wouldn't make
a billion dollars
oh yeah you're right 650 and it doesn't
cover [ __ ] yeah that's a good point I
pay my car insurance every month then
when I get an accident I still have to
pay what I've been paying y'all for
years and you also legally have to have
it [ __ ] car insurance so it's like oh
wow how great to open a car insurance
company bro we will overcome this [ __ ]
bro did you know that car company I mean
insurance companies make a [ __ ] ton of
money do
it just proves all state State Farm
no it just bounces as much money as you
think they do all state gotta pay that
dennis haysbert building man he's been
cashing out on that first cert ever
he's an off-day guy who's like you're in
good hands
you know you commercial gig is the
cushiest gig ever
this is so sick he's like I can film
this [ __ ] in my robe like Flo from
progressive ya know she's been a million
dollars day for us what the Sprint guy
he moved on over
he was a guy is [ __ ] for sale bro
he's going to t-mobile next you'll see
this Canadian family was vacationing in
Florida when all of a sudden the 87 year
old dad died of a heart attack when they
were there and so the family was just so
terrified of dealing with us health care
[ __ ] stuff that they ended up doing
a weekend at Bernie's type scenario and
they actually drove to Canada from
Florida with the weight it's cheaper to
bury them in Canada or some [ __ ] no it's
because when you call the [ __ ]
paramedics they have to you know do all
that pole thing and then just bringing
them up in the system the hospital
system that's mud houses [ __ ]
money man there was this um so the US
healthcare system has been known to
bankrupt some commands so there was this
one man who needed treatment after a car
accident and ended up owing three
hundred and twenty-five thousand dollars
his other one a woman she gave birth
prematurely and had to pay nearly 1
million why this guy's like okay what
I'll do is I I got three hundred
thousand dollar bill okay I'll fake my
own death he's like I'll but then I got
to pay funeral costs music oh
are they dropping Florida back to Canada
with the dead body
how did it rack up so do you know the
other stories like 300 thousand 1
million that's close man they they they
charge you for everything when I had my
first moon night I had my first kid I
was there though well my wife had my
first son yeah we charge for the [ __ ]
water that they gave you
bottles and they like hey take bottles
take blankets I'm like yo man we need
all that then I got the bill like
literally every bottle that he drank
they charged that bottles that you took
a little freaking Sox premium like what
are these Gucci socks they're gonna be
like $1,000 yeah because they know
they're billing your insurance most of
time so it's like ah but but if you have
no insurance you just got to pay 30
grand 50 grand under gran-gran on
average to have a baby well if you have
no insurance can't you just go to the
government and be like help me yes
Healthcare eBay they have to give you
only if you're under the law of the line
of poverty yes so like thirty years
thirty thousand or something like 25
that's like 25 Wow if I move my taxes
correctly I could look bankrupt dude
what about poor Jeff Bezos who who
doesn't have any income and all he
doesn't pay no taxes poverty line or no
Amazon
man that tax law stuff it's so
frustrating you guys and [ __ ] genius
they just hire tax people from the IRS
to be like hey how can we not pay taxes
yeah and they make it it maximize growth
and I get food stamps but they spend a
lot of money they spend a lot of money
to make that happen yeah so because they
have millions to have a whole team to
just work those taxes yeah offshore
accounts all that stuff that's why they
can make it work so we come on the
weekend you wait like Amazon crazy and
there's like all these box
[Applause]
it's like Christmas for a dog
and you know what's in there it doesn't
matter like what is it
toilet tissue but for me the same way
because they were born into it you know
how it like we used to wait forever to
get a letter in the mail like you know
like if anything had our name on it in
the mail it was like a big deal if kids
feel that way I love the junk mail where
it was like if you get something and
it's like surprise you may have won
$10,000 already you ever get those yeah
didn't you have to boot yeah and I
[ __ ] got my grandma to put the
address in and her name and send a check
and I was like we're gonna win grandma
we're gonna [ __ ] do this you see that
[ __ ] works like Publishers Clearing
House is like you've already won a
million basically like you're already
set job you're already set you might
wanna write in your book and Edie why
don't you do this one time we wrote into
a sweepstakes cuz it was like they were
giving away free hot air balloon rides
if you won this thing and every day I
waited by the mailbox because I wanted
to yeah yeah I thought like so be
submitted I'm like we gotta win this I
was like give me here yet did we hear
about but they said they helped you
submit it yeah no and now I'm too scared
no too scared of my own stories about
that [ __ ] dude so I get I get a call
from pretty routinely every month and
it's always like you want a free cruise
and they always say like you want to
cruise sir and I always go like holy
[ __ ] I put the phone up here so they can
see I only get here kind of way all
right holy [ __ ] go yeah
like I do that whole thing and then I
hang up YouTube videos that are there
scamming the scammers
I love the scam calls are right through
the roof now from India yeah make all
with a number that's like very similar
to your number and now I just don't
answer if it's not a number in my phone
already because now it's a scam like
unlikely but that's when I'm like who
time to put on my old man voice oh yeah
you guys don't have to say I never got
scammed likely i got spring they always
call it the most inconvenient time
though because when i pick up i want to
record it and have a conversation it
might be good entertainment right but
then they call you when you're busy yeah
you don't want to pick on driving yeah
it's cuz they're on india time oh yeah
they need some india gamers that are
night owls that can like all the videos
it's all india centres true yeah so
bison is family here so they almost made
it home in canada there were 15 minutes
north of the border but then that's when
they caught them oh [ __ ] well so they're
saying that charges haven't been filed
yet even know how to make that uh what
is it what's the crime is there a lot of
says you can't carry a dead body that
person that died naturally i obviously
be killed him but it did that naturally
is that Olivos transporting our own
family member body yeah well and they
also found that there was no no sign of
violence and they died of a heart attack
but so once they the paramedics saw him
they said that he was a day or two dead
already
doesn't the body start to smell after
that yeah thanks i'm sure do you
remember a little miss sunshine did they
do that little miss sunshine good they
mentioned in this - i never saw the end
of it I just mean either they basically
put the dad in trash bag or some [ __ ] I
hadn't keep driving yeah wait cuz it
cost it cost money they were they're
poor so like it was something like that
where it cost them money to keep him in
the hospital and he was already dead and
so
all right healthcare systems but I would
rather drive with a dead body for three
days didn't have to deal with American
health care system that is expensive
like if someone dies I can't you just
let them die I know you just bury people
funerals are a big business they are go
fund these no celebrities
[Music]